years
i'm sorry to interrupt you as you see
that the police there that there's
there's already some trouble they're
beating the crowd back here
while
the the casket has been
taken through the gates there they're
holding back
large numbers of the crowd but um
i'm not sure what what what what's going
on here you can see these pictures too
right
[Applause]
my wife speaking we can't hear him hang
on a second
[Applause]
i think we can hear you now
i have never seen
security forces attack a funeral with
such
audacity with such chutzpah
the way this scene is evolving right now
in front of us
they are trying to carry
and they're trying to bury
one of their own and the police is there
as if there is an enemy ahead of them
it's their own victim being buried and
here they are with such
with such an incredible incredible
rudeness
again i mean i have i have reported i
have analyzed i've looked at news
throughout the world for decades and
i've never seen a scene like this look
at that
attacking innocent people carrying a
casket
i i don't know what to say i don't know
what to say anymore
what are they expecting now
this is unbelievable
unbelievable
[Applause]
my god
[Applause]
such disrespect
for the dead and for those who are
mourning the dead
[Applause]
[Applause]
us how are these people a threat to
israel
how are they a threat to security they
are in their portugal
trying to mourn
one of their own dead how is that a
security threat to anyone
how is that disorderly
why does that require this kind of
repression this kind of violence on the
part of israelis
and again these people are under orders
to carry such an attack
these people don't
carry such attack on their own they have
been ordered
to do this
and the world
is watching
the world
is watching
[Applause]
and probably they will be spoiling it
tomorrow counter terrorism i want to
know how is this a security threat how
is this terrorism
to be attacking innocent people
civilians
trying to mourn
one of their own a victim
of israeli occupation
[Applause]
unprecedented
utterly
criminal
inhumane
[Music]
this is
the so-called one and only democracy in
the middle east
[Applause]
in the middle of jerusalem
the holy city
where a journalist
killed yesterday is being honored by her
own community by her family and fans
being disrupted by israeli security
forces
colonial forces
unheard of unseen before unprecedented
[Applause]
this is this is the time for
for international
for outside
powers to intervene
palestinian people need do need
protection
all right would this is the time
for the u.n to
words
intervene
fail me
astonishing scenes here from from
occupied east jerusalem
um
i i don't know i just want to try and
work out what what actually happened
here i think we've got we can show you
some some pictures
of of of what happened a few moments ago
mama you can see them on the on the
right hand side of your screen
where the police
i don't know what these police thought
they were trying to do at this point
there was no one threatening them
whether they were trying to hold the
crowd back to stop them leaving
their soldiers no not police
um i don't know whether they were trying
to hold the crowd back to stop them
um following
the coffin as it as it was taken out of
that compound i i don't i i can't work
out what they were what they were doing
do you have any can you
do you have any idea marwan from what
you can see there
i i think
they probably thought
that whatever orders they gave whatever
presumably understanding that they had
that
what the funeral is supposed to be like
and who's supposed to go out and in and
who's supposed to honor shireen whatever
they have in their mind nothing excuses
nothing justifies
nothing justifies an attack on innocent
people carrying a coffin
trying to honor
trying to bury one of their own
absolutely nothing justifies that
nothing excuses that those security
forces are not supposed to be in a
courtyard
what are they doing in the courtyard
when no one is being
threatened you know we try to
we try to we as rational human being we
try to understand we try to
reach some sort of reasonable conclusion
but this
image adrian
has no explanation
this is madness how do you explain
madness how do you justify madness
i'm sure they i mean you want to
investigate investigate here you have
okay it's right there it's clear to the
whole world to see
ma
many thanks indeed for that stay with us
stay with us i just want to go to um
live talking about east jerusalem
my colleague imran khan is is on the
processional route
not far from the church where the
funeral service is due to happen a
little later
imran
what are you hearing about about what's
going on here at the
moment well what's going on is there was
some uh pushing and shoving between the
israeli army and the people who wanted
to take sharim's body our colleague uh
to where i'm standing right now they
wanted to walk with her body they didn't
want to go in the car the israeli army
suggests said that they were only
allowed to take her by car there was
intense negotiations going on indeed our
bureau chief of al jazeera arabic for uh
jerusalem will lead armory but was
surrounded by people they were asking
him to try and intervene of course he
couldn't do anything and then we saw the
israeli forces enter the courtyard using
stone grenades using smoke grenades and
that's why we see the scenes that are
taking place right now all of this is
happening because the israeli police
will not allow them to walk it's a
45-minute walk from where they are to
where we are it would have been a very
peaceful walk but now things are
escalating
this is going to delay everything
significantly there'll also be big
problems within the area itself within
the area itself is sheikh jarrah you may
remember protests taking place in
shakedira over the last year where is
israelis forcibly evicted palestinian
families already a source of quite big
attention a lot of those families
are there to show their support for
sharing
like i said earlier she's known here as
the daughter of jerusalem this
outpouring of emotion now is turned
violent and that's because the israeli
army the israeli soldiers entered in to
the courtyard
we're seeing now uh a hearse uh
has been reversed uh to the back of the
hospital where shereen's casket is
uh right now i'm imran and as you as you
said it seems that that
the uh the security forces have uh have
got their way that they're not allowing
uh any sort of procession
uh to to walk uh to with serene's casket
to walk to the church where the funeral
service is due to be held it appears
from what we're seeing now that her
casket will be driven uh to the church
that's right well that's what we're
hearing we're not sure that crowd isn't
going to really back down though it
wants to be able to make the walk and
i'm just going to get out the way and
show you the scene here uh the israeli
soldiers the israeli police rather have
actually barricaded off the entrance
into the church they're allowing
residents to go in and people who want
to go to the funeral service but we've
already been told by people who have
approached us the israeli police are
actually asking whether you're christian
or muslim if you're muslim they're not
allowing you in we've heard that from
two people have actually come up to us
and told us that so
by the time the procession actually gets
here we are expecting a large number of
crowds but like you say those pictures
that you're seeing uh from uh the top of
a sheikh jarrah from where the french
hospital is where the mall where my
colleague's body lays
whether that's going to happen anytime
soon remains to be seen but the key now
is these pros these uh mourners who want
to walk with the body i don't know for
that going to be allowed to happen
there's confusion here as to whether uh
and how they're going to reach it
all right
stay with us so we're still seeing these
these live pictures here and it's very
difficult for you uh because you're out
on the street that you can't actually
see what's what's going on at the moment
we can
uh the the hearse uh
carrying shadeen's casket is now
beginning
uh to move
through this crowd
now towards the gate of the of that
compound
and let's just remind you that earlier
uh mourners tried to to carry shireen's
coffin the coffin rather
out of that hospital compound but the
the israeli army
uh
started to uh
to attack people who were who were
carrying the coffin uh this apparently
is because they refused to allow it to
be carried through the streets to
uh the church where the funeral services
is due to happen it now seems that that
a hearse
will be
carrying her body to the church
uh
as uh as we speak um
that hurts moving very slowly
through that crowd that is gathered
there at the french hospital people
obviously
uh still very angry uh
feelings running
very very
high uh
let's just i'm just gonna let this play
out for a moment let's just let's just
listen and watch to
what's going on here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
flowers being thrown onto the roof of
the house they're carrying our colleague
shireen's
uh body
and
the army they're pulling down pulling
off palestinian flags that have been
that that mourners have tried to uh to
put onto the
vehicle as it left so that the hearse
has now left the compound
uh the army they're stopping mourners
from
leaving the compound and accompanying
the hearse but a lot of people though
still outside
as you can see they're pulling people
now out of the hearse
uh mourners who who are inside the house
with shireen's casket are being forcibly
removed
and the vehicle now being allowed to uh
to continue uh its journey
imran as i said i know you you couldn't
see any of that but but you could you
could certainly hear what was going on
and you could hear my description of it
it seems now that the hearse is
or has begun to make its way
uh toward you there
[Applause]
well
well actually adrian i can see the
pictures we have a screen here where i'm
looking all those which are also getting
information uh from that area as well
now the car has actually left it's about
a 10 minute drive to where we are now uh
the mourners will leave that area
they'll also either walk or get in cars
and come here but that's the street down
there where they're going to come where
the greek patriarch very key church is
where the funeral service is going to
take place the israeli police are
checking ids of everybody walking in
we've already heard as i said
but the israeli police are asking people
whether they're christian or muslim if
you're muslim they're not allowing you
in that's been told to us by two
different people who have come who have
just told us that all they really want
to do is come in and pay their last
respects that's the scene there at the
scene at the french hospital that is a
huge crowd we weren't expecting a number
of uh people a crowd that large to be
there at that moment we were expecting a
large crowd to be here indeed
a lot of israeli police are actually
backing up i've seen one two three four
vehicles actually go past us into
the street adjacent to us and a large
number of police walk in so clearly the
israeli police have mounted a very big
security operation but remember this is
just a the second part the funeral
service that takes place here uh is
going to be uh is going to take place
very shortly once that body arrives
all right imran many thanks indeed for
the moment we'll be back with you uh
shortly that's uh al jazeera's imran
khan uh they're in occupied east
jerusalem
as i said earlier i mean it's words
family here these astonishing scenes
that we're seeing
there uh from
occupied east jerusalem
just want to bring in uh al jazeera's uh
senior political analyst marwan bashara
again uh he's in london and he's been
watching this unfold with us
over the uh the last 15 20 minutes or so
where do we start with this
well you know we start actually on on
the idea that um all of this if it was
meant to
implement a certain policy it could have
been done
in a non-violent way you have overly
armed security forces
facing down
a few civilian women and men
trying to honor
their dead
family member or colleague
the fact that such violence was used
could not be justified by any security
means or by any policy means
the the way you and i and the rest of
the world has watched can only be
explained by sadism
humiliation
breaking down the will of those people
who are trying to honor a colleague
a family member
what's what i'm really trying to focus
on is the fact that even if israel
wanted certain things to go in a certain
way
such violence against a funeral
against civilians is unprecedented
it can only be explained by a certain
sadism
humiliation violence and a habit just as
we are seeing now
there is no need for such an overly
armed security forces and army
to be attacking
people in mourning people in mourning
which means passive
which means in a solemn moment in their
life trying to honor one of their own
so the fact that there is such a
humiliation
such breaking of of of a will of a
people
with such sadism
that is unprecedented
and all of this
being broadcast live
to the world
absolutely you know
we've heard before and i you know i've
i've i've learned it over the years and
i've taught it over the years but i
never really understood it
there is this uh mantra in israel that
says israel will do what it must and the
world could say whatever it will
and
and it's only now that it's hauntingly
what this actually means that israel
will do whatever it wants
any which way it wants
and it doesn't matter what the rest of
the world thinks it certainly doesn't
matter as long as london and washington
and paris are supporting the the israeli
government who cares what the rest of
the world says right but that's the
situation we're faced with that israel
is doing whatever israel wants including
attacking a peaceful funeral and a
courtyard
in a courtyard not threatening anyone
not not instigating against anyone
not menacing anyone
and they could have stopped it by simply
blocking their way out of the courtyard
but the way they were attacked the way
they were humiliated by bats and batons
that's just meant to humiliate that's
just sadistic that's just
utterly mad that cannot be excused or
justified or explained away
by some sort of a
security uh
logic or rationale there is no security
logical rationale in beating up people
in a funeral in a portal
[Music]
to talk about about the way the world's
reaction in in the way that
the world
seems to look the other way sometimes
when when injustice like this as as
we're seeing it play out here
um
goes on we as you know in here in the
studio we have a computer which which is
in front of us which our viewers can't
see but but when we're sitting here in
front of the camera we we can see and it
has the latest breaking news stories
coming in from news agencies all over
the world
uh and i was just looking down to see
what what the news agencies were saying
about about what we're what we're seeing
here uh marwan
so far there's there's one
breaking news alert as as they call it
from the
agents
france press news agency it says
violence erupts
as journalists coffin emerges from
jerusalem hospital
that's it violence erupts
but you know i yeah i think i think
moving forward uh uh adrian i mean i
have i have a hunch and
it kind of changed over the days i mean
two days ago i was yesterday morning i
was quite pessimistic and depressed
about all of this
but i'm beginning to think more and more
that perhaps we are at
some sort of a crossroad at this point
in time with these events taking place
and not just because of the killing of
our colleague because of israel's
behavior because of the arrogance of
israel power and you know arrogance
breeds
stupidity
and what we're seeing and rival in front
of our eyes now is sadistic stupidity
and i tell you
how i see this and why i think this
might actually be something more than
what it is and the way you and i are
looking at it
i am old enough to remember
images from a naked vietnamese woman
burned by the napalm
changing the course of the war in
vietnam not because the image changed
because it was a breaking point in that
war in vietnam and that image expressed
the change in the war in vietnam i
remember the killing of a nicaraguan
journalist changed
the somoza government in nicaragua i
remember
taking out dead nuns in el salvador that
image
changing the course of the civil war in
salvador i remember abu ghraib
and that how that was the cross that was
the turning point for the american war
in iraq
i remember the image of muhammad
killed in the in the arms of his father
in gaza in 2000 and how that image was a
turning point for israel to withdraw out
of gaza in 2005.
i remember images like that i remember
image of the young palestinian
all right
generation slapping an israelite soldier
just few
let's go back to imran khan in occupied
east jerusalem um the the hearse
carrying uh shillin's casket has now
arrived there uh imran
yeah the casket is inside that car just
there with the cross on top it is going
up into the church which is going to get
slightly closer to give you a better
look you see all the people around us
they're clapping
shireen's body is now entering
entering inside a palestinian flag has
been hoisted up
the car slowly makes its way through
that packed crowd
the israeli police are now moving in to
remove that flag
the flag is still being waved we're
being pushed back
the israeli police are
pushing us back now i know if you can
still hear me i think you can
the israeli police want to remove that
palestinian flag the palestinian flag is
actually illegal
to downplay
push this back with a car
carrying that casket is still moving
ever closer to the church it's only
a few meters up the road
the israeli police
you can see they're pushing us back from
this barricade
and the car is going
through
so that's where the funeral service is
taking place
lots of people surrounding us you can
probably hear
so that idea of people actually walking
uh hasn't happened the body has been
brought here by car as you've just seen
adrian
all right many thanks indeed for the
moment as you see there the the hearse
carrying our colleague
serena abu ah clear has now arrived
at
the church where the funeral service
uh will happen very
shortly let's let's just listen in once
again to to the atmosphere
[Applause]
foreign
by our blood at our soul we will revenge
our death they were they were chanting
your death they were chanting uh there
that uh as we heard
that the crowd um
who were pushed back
by
uh israeli forces not allowed to uh to
follow the coffin as far as the
uh the church
let's uh
go live now to my colleague nick clark
uh who is he's very near to where where
imran is and where these pictures we're
seeing uh right now are coming from nick
tell us something about the the mood
there right now
adrian thanks so much yes indeed so
imran is at the other end of the street
this is the church building here the
catholic church
where the funeral ceremony is going to
take place there's going to be a service
in there
mr right i don't think our picture can
show you that but you can uh
rehearse arrived after
the israeli
scenes were sort of israeli security
forces
saying that they could not the
procession couldn't walk here that they
had to drive here in the house that is
now right the body has arrived i'm going
to straight away go to
reverend father simon cory who's
actually going to take
take over the
part of the clergy here is going to take
over the service and talk about it what
do you make sir first of all the scenes
that we've seen
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and i want to tell you that
nobody can compare the palestinian case
with any other
violence in the world or any other world
because any nation that had a war they
they still have their identity their
flag their land but we lost our land our
identity our flag and we are we the
palestinians were occupated from other
nations so you cannot compare the
palestinian case and the palestinian
problem with any other war in the world
i know you need to go because you're
going to take part in conducting the
service in a second but can anything
good come out of this appalling terrible
tragedy could there be a force for
change in any way i think shireen above
the land
she had influence but shireen ander
dalanchi will have millions times of
influence than she was before if someone
imagined that the influence of sharing
will stop
no
now she will have influence all over the
world and we believe we don't believe in
the
love of the power we believe in the
power of love
we don't believe in the power of of
violence never and we don't believe in
the armament we believe in god we
believe in love we believe in peace we
are people of peace and we hope that the
people that take decisions in the world
they will
come back in this jerusalem jesus said
on the cross
father
pardon them because they don't know what
they do
and after
2022 years i repeat in jerusalem on the
same place that jesus was walking
in the via de la rosa
god pardoned them because they don't
know what they say and what they do
have you been surprised by the strength
of feeling
what have you been surprised by the
strength of feeling that we're seeing
here today
i am never surprised you can be in your
life you can be sad you can be happy but
never be surprised even when shirin was
killed i was not surprised because
everything is expected in this in this
world
because
the man
should be brother for his
for his brother the man not to be wolf
for him and kill him
so we better let you go father thank you
so much indeed for your time i do
appreciate it that's father curry he's
actually taking part in the service that
will be getting underway very soon uh
not quite sure what's happened as far as
i can see
i can see the coffin now being carried
into the church you can see how packed
it is and how many thousands of people
there are
along the route that there have been
let's have a listen into what's going on
[Music]
elephant
[Applause]
telephone telephone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
hey
foreign
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hey
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
oh
be careful and run
[Music]
special forces
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah i'm ready
so in the last in the last 20 minutes
[Music]
so in the last 20 minutes what just
happened is the
car carrying serene casket went into
the church there was a palestinian flag
in the back the israeli police smashed
that to take the flag then there was a
protest that just happened people
protesting uh one man raised the
palestinian flag raising the palestinian
flag is actually illegal in israel and
then the police moved in
to try and take the flag and now
scuffles are taking place they're
arresting a man
for chanting and the israeli police are
now
beating on that man you can see
he's trying to escape
[Applause]
you can see the tensions here uh he's
surrounded by israeli police they're
beating him
to try and arrest him he doesn't have a
flag there
me
these people are
angry and they're shouting he's just out
of shot the man has now been arrested
there's a huge crowd here at uh jaffa
gate the entrance to the tent where the
funeral service is taking place now the
israeli police are still in that area
they've arrested one man just as we were
live on air but this was a protest
against the fact that shireen's body
wasn't allowed to walk here these people
are now
chanting for national palestinian unity
and slogans in support of sharing the
israeli police have now mounted a
barrier stopping anybody from going
further from this area
i'm just going to stop talking for a
second to give you a sense of what
people are saying what people are
talking
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
m
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is right down to the other end of the
street
and the church itself is right here
where we're seeing the pictures
of the
ceremony the ceremony going on and the
the relative tranquility of inside the
church is uh far cry from what's going
on outside as you can see
the israeli soldiers have been
piling in on the
mourners who've been
trying to proceed with the coffin in the
first place
[Music]
a booty as a palestinian human rights
lawyer
dinah we were talking on thursday the
day shireen died
and it's extraordinary that we're here
now and you can just see the high
emotions
and there's no surprise at all no not at
all
so many people and her
her killing
is a blow to the world internationally
it's a blow to us nationally and it's a
blow to me personally she went into the
hearts of every single palestinian and i
dare say every arab
household because of her touching
reporting and the way that she had of
bringing to life the reality of israel's
brutal occupation i'm not surprised by
this at all right yeah this is the
intensity of reaction and how widespread
it is i mean not just here in uh
east jerusalem but right across the
world yes her funeral procession began
in in geneva in the northern part of
palestine went through nablus and down
to ramallah and from ramallah into
jerusalem
we've been saying that she went from the
from the earth of palestine to the gates
of heaven from janine all the way up to
jerusalem and she deserves it
so what now
where can we extract something positive
well i think
i think that what's very important is
that we have to demand accountability
from israel it must be said over and
over again
shidian would not have been engineering
had the israeli army not been engineered
and they are 100 responsible for her
murder they know it we know it and these
attempts to try to hide to obfuscate to
pretend that it's somebody else these
fake calls for an investigation we've
seen this time and again what now must
happen is that israel must be held
accountable we've been saying this time
and time again shadian is not the first
journalist to be killed by israel and i
i fear that she's not going to be the
last either it's now time for
accountability and we must demand that
israel be held accountable because it is
israel who is responsible but hasn't
that demand being made for a very long
time to absolutely no effect whatsoever
it has been been made for such a long
time i'm hoping now with shadin's very
uh she had a very high profile and she
touched so many that people would now
realize and understand the importance of
holding israel accountable you know this
isn't the first time as i mentioned just
a few years ago we saw them kill a
palestinian photographer in the gaza
strip
and later it emerged that we saw videos
of israeli soldiers cheering themselves
on for for hitting palestinians this is
the type of action that has to come up
to an end and i i believe that with
shidian's murder that the world will now
see that it's time for them to act if
not we're going to continue to see this
time and again well those scenes we saw
just what half an hour ago 40 minutes
ago outside the hospital as a casket was
being brought out and people just wanted
to walk here they wanted to mourn and
pay their respects in
in a civilized fashion but
it wasn't allowed to happen by the
israeli soldiers but this is what it
means to live under a military
occupation is that they try to control
your happiness and they try to control
your morning the fact that they were
fighting with with uh mourners that they
were shooting sun grenades at them that
they were beating them up all because
they wanted to carry her casket through
the streets of jerusalem the place that
she loved the most on the on this earth
it shows the depths the depravity that
israel's military occupation has
there's a great deal of anger isn't
there a great deal of anger now and it
always has been but particularly because
of this and we're seeing it come to life
in these streets this afternoon
do you think that that will build that
that may actually
gain momentum for certain
undoubtedly you know
her her funeral today is is both anger
but it's also a celebration of her life
people who are cheering are celebrating
her life and thanking her
for the more than 25 years that she gave
in in in telling our story and
portraying to the world what it's like
for us to live under israeli military
rule so these these chants that you're
hearing are also a celebration of her
life as well as the the compounded anger
particularly the way that she was killed
and the attempts to
try to pretend that it wasn't them who
did it when we know that it
was the kids
[Applause]
[Applause]
united states have said that israel are
perfectly capable of carrying out a
thorough and fair and
transparent investigation
while israel has the support of the
united states
there's never going to be progress no
there's never going to be an
investigation and we don't need one we
know exactly how it was that she was
killed we have video evidence of it but
more importantly we have eyewitness
testimony what is it that an
investigation is going to produce that
the very people whose job it is to
highlight and to tell the truth what is
it that this investigation is going to
do we've seen this in the past where
israel claims that they're going to
carry out investigations and they don't
it's just a way of buying more time of
keeping people quiet until the next
murder and again it's this hasbro these
propaganda 101. step one is to try to
obfuscate to blame somebody else or to
blame palestinians for their own deaths
step two is to call for some fake
investigation which leads to nowhere and
step three is to perhaps say i'm sorry
we've been down this path before and we
know where it leads and we know that at
the end of the day nothing is going to
come out of it this is where it's time
for international accountability that
the international world has to put
pressure on israel to end this and the
fact that we are been saying this time
and again
it's you know
is is just devastating to palestinians
because we keep saying how much more is
it that the world needs to see before
they wake up and realize that this
apartheid regime has to come to an end
there is a case coming before the
international criminal court it said
that sharing's murder will add it to
that
any recourse
[Applause]
because the court system takes a very
very very long time but i want to say
that this isn't the first time that
israel has targeted al jazeera we saw
just last year that they bombed the al
jazeera building and the ap
we saw just last year that they broke
the arm of gibbard
colleague and friend and now this year
this
in 2017 the israeli government said that
they were going to do their best to shut
down
them and we see that that they are doing
exactly what it is that they want to do
it's only through international
accountability that this will come to an
end
so we're seeing pictures from inside the
church
uh on half of our screens of the
ceremony that's going on uh
tell us a little bit more about serena
what kind of person she was
was a wonderful person i i don't think
there are words that i can say that
won't lead me to cry
when talking about shitty she was kind
she was generous she had a great sense
of humor a fantastic laugh was as humble
as humble can be didn't really
understand how well loved she was by by
the world
and above all else she loved her job
and she loved
she loved shedding light on palestine
she was
i can't believe that we're even speaking
about her in the past tense
okay thank you so much i know we're
going to talk to you a little bit later
so hang around if you can in this in
this very busy crowd i do appreciate
that very much
as you see the service is still going on
and uh once it's complete it shouldn't
be too long now
then shereen's body and casket will be
taken to mount zion to the cemetery
there
and quite how
that will go remains to be seen it's
going to be
quite a tricky thing to extract
the casket into the crowds here and then
back out onto the main streets at where
we
what's going on inside the church
[Music]
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
whoa